take us to one of your cold calls the
moment the phone picks up hello usually
it's a producer because nobody deals
with producers and I had a producer
early on tell me you know nobody gives
us the respect we're part of the team
too and I thought AHA opportunity so
usually I've written to the producer and
asked could I give you a call this
happened after take this lollipop I
contacted producers of German content
for German television because take this
lollipop ran on der spiegel TV and I had
a bite and so we set up a phone
conference and it was by Skype and you
know they're in Berlin and I'm here and
they say hello how are you and I said
you know I'm fine how are you did you
get a chance to take a look at the
lollipop go ahead and it immediately
begin don't waste their time immediately
began and they'll say yes we did well
that ended up turn it into a little
production deal from that company from a
cold call so but for every one of those
it works you know you go through 79 that
don't in terms of the cold call
etiquette how do you approach it are you
long-winded and friendly and jovial in
your approach no very business minded
you have to be who you are as a person
and that'll come through your
naturalness and I'm not long winded I'm
not jovial and at parties I just stand
in the corner and want to talk about
serious subjects so that's not who I am
so if I'm calling you but like I'm Karen
how are you and once you say fine i'm
done with the joviality I'm ready to
move on to the business I think you have
to be yourself so you say hi how are you
and I say fine I'll say great I wanted
to talk to you about blah blah blah the
same with an email um hi Karen hope
you've been will I'm writing because
blah blah I want that second sentence to
tell you why is this because a lot of
times I'll get an email or even a phone
call and I don't know what they want all
I need to know in the course of my day
is what do you want from me and I don't
mean that in a bad way I just mean let's
begin the dialogue what is it that you
want and if you're not asking for the
sale and making the request and telling
me what you want I can't tell you
if I can help you or not and I go
through three paragraphs of the email
and I just get discouraged and I'll just
save it an archive and say I'm going to
look at this later and then a month
later they'll call and say did you ever
look at so and so and what I want to say
is just tell me what you want so yeah be
being direct really helps with his
business of course it was a long-winded
answer wasn't very direct
you